RELENTLESSLY BOMBARD THE STEEL
PLANT IN THE BESIEGED AND
ESSENTIALLY CONQUESTIONER STORY
OF MARIUPOL ON THE SOUTH COAST.
SOME OF THE LATEST CIVILIANS TO
EVACUATE FROM THE STEEL PLANT.
YET THESE ARE RUSH TROOPS, NOT
THE UNITED NATIONS PEOPLE THAT
HELPED TO EVACUATE.
WHILE UKRAINE SAID IT BEGAN A
NEW OPERATION TO GET PEOPLE OUT
FROM UNDER THIS, THE SALVE RAJRY
OF RUSSIAN BOMBARDMENT AT THE
FACTORY, THE U.N. SAID FRIDAY A
TOTAL OF 500 PEOPLE HAD GOT OUT
SINCE THEIR EFFORTS BEGAN THIS
WEEKEND, MANY, MANY MORE
DESPERATE TO FLEE.
BATTERED AND UNHABITABLE AS MUCH
OF MARIUPOL IS, STILL AHEAD OF
MONDAY ACE VICTORY DAY, IT
APPEARS THE DRAMA THEATER
BASEMENT IS PACKED WITH CHILDREN
WHEN IT WAS BOMBED BY RUSSIA,
KILLING HUNDREDS, IS NOTHING
BEING CLEARED UP.
VEHICLES LINED UP AND THE GROUND
AROUND THE THEATER CLEARED TO
MAKE IT MORE PRESENTABLE.
IT'S NOT CLEAR WHY THEY ARE
TIDYING THE SCENE OF WHAT MANY
CALLED A WAR CRIME.
THE WARPED WORLD OF WHAT RUSSIA
CALLS LIBERATION WAS ALSO ON
VIEW HERE IN THESE RARE IMAGES
FILMED INAISLE A FILTRATION
CAMP, WHERE UKRAINIANS ARE HELD
BEFORE BEING FORCED TO GO TO
RUSSIA, PASSPORTS TAKEN,
SLEEPING ON THE FLOOR ON IN
CHAIRS, ILLNESS FROM THE COLD,
ALL PART OF THE EXPERIENCE OF
LIBERATION, ACCORDING TO ONE
WOMAN WHOSE FATHER WAS THERE.
AND THIS STAGED VISIT, EVIDENCE
OF RUSSIA'S RUSH TO ASSIMILATE
WHAT IT CLUMSILY TORN OFF
UKRAINE.
THIS IS THE FIRST CITY IT
CAPTURED, AND THE MAN IN THE
BEARD IS DENNIS SEPARATIST
LEADER FROM DONETSK, ON THE
RUSSIAN OCCUPATION WHERE
PROTESTS ARE CRUSHED, WILL ALSO
BE KILLED -- IT ALL HAS THE
WHIFF OF EMPIRE.
HERE HE DISCUSSION TRANSFERRING
FOOD, WATERMELON AND TOMATOES,
HE MIGHT CALL IT TRADE.
UKRAINE A FOOD HEIST.
BUT MOSCOW IS FAR FROM HAVING
ITS WAY AND THE COSTS ARE HEAVY.
THESE IMAGES CNN HAS CONFIRMED
WERE FILMED IN A GRAVE-YARD, THE
FLAGS OVER THE RUSSIAN PARATROOP
DIVISION, THE ELITE, AND THERE
ARE MANY JUST IN THIS ONE CITY.
THESE ARE THE DEAD BEHIND THE
PROPAGANDA, WITH SO MUCH RUBBLE
IN RUSSIA'S TINY VICTORIES.
NOW, PAMELA, WELL, OF COURSE WE
ARE LOOKING AT INCREMENTAL
ADVANCES BY RUSSIA IN TERRITORY
HERE INSIDE OF UKRAINE.
THERE ARE CONCERNS EXTERNAL THAT
AHEAD OF MONDAY'S MAY 9th
VICTORY PARADES, WHERE RUSSIA
TRADITIONAL CELEBRATES ITS
VICTORY OVER NAZIS -- CURIOUS
THEY WOULD CHOOSE TO REVIVE THAT
AND THE LUDICROUS NOTION OF THE
INVASION OF UKRAINE, THERE MAY
BE A FINAL PUSH IN THE DAYS
AHEAD, SPECIFICALLY IN THE EAST.
THERE'S A CONCERN THAT MIGHT BE
THE FOCUS OF